♪ ♪
>> Dagen: FROM JERRY SEINFELD
TO DAVE CHAPPELLE, COMEDIANS
HAVE BEEN CALLING OUT
CANCEL CULTURE AND POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS BUT SETH ROGEN
THINKS THEY SHOULD STOP
COMPLAINING AND JUST ACCEPT IT.
>> SAYING TERRIBLE THINGS IS
BAD.
IF YOU SAID SOMETHING TERRIBLE
THAT SOMETHING YOU SHOULD
CONFRONT IN SOME WAY, SHAPE, OR
FORM.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S
CANCEL CULTURE, THAT'S YOU
SAYING SOMETHING TERRIBLE IF
THAT'S WHAT YOU'VE DONE.
B5 HE IS FINE FOR YOU, GREG, YOU
HAVE A BACKBONE AND YOU ARE
HILARIOUS UNLIKE SETH ROGEN.
>> Greg: PROBABLY THE DUMBEST
ARGUMENT ANYONE CAN MAKE WHEN
THEY ARE DISMISSING OUR CONCERN
IS THAT IT'S NEVER BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR ME.
I HAVE HEARD PEOPLE USE THAT
ARGUMENT WHEN THERE ARE TRUE
CLAIMS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
WHEN THERE ARE FALSE CLAIMS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
"IT'S NEVER BEEN A PROBLEM FOR
ME," IT CAN BASICALLY TRANSLATE
INTO DO NOT LOOK TO ME FOR ANY
SUPPORT WHEN YOU GET IN TROUBLE.
YOU SAW HIS BEST FRIEND JAMES
FRANCO WHO IS A SLEAZY GUY BUT
SETH ROGEN KNEW HE WAS A SLEAZY
GUY, HE WORKED WITH THEM FOR
YEARS UNTIL JAMES FRANCO GOT TO
SLEAZY END SETH ROGEN DROPPED
HIM LIKE A HOT POTATO.
NOT A VERY GOOD ANALOGY BUT
ANYWAY, MAYBE SETH DOESN'T HAVE
TO WORRY FOR A FEW REASONS.
HE IS COMPLETELY INOFFENSIVE
LATELY, HE'S NEVER SET A
SHOCKING THING IN HIS LIFE
EXCEPT MAYBE TURNING DOWN A
JOINT, HE'S VERY LIBERAL SO THAT
WILL OFFER HIM SOME COVER BUT
THERE'S ONE THING HE MIGHT HAVE
TO REVISIT AND THAT IS THE RAPE
SCENE IN "OBSERVE AND REPORT"
WHICH MANY WOULD SAY IS PLAYED
FOR LAUGHS.
MAYBE YOU FORGOT ABOUT THAT, I
DON'T KNOW BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THAT MAY END UP HAUNTING
HIM ALTHOUGH I DON'T THINK HE
SHOULD BE CANCELED FOR IT
BECAUSE HE'S A CHARACTER.
>> Dagen: DANA?
>> Dana: I NOTICED THAT HE SET
IT ON GOOD MORNING BRITAIN AND
OF COURSE, NO FIRST AMENDMENT
THERE SO THEY HAVE ISSUES RATE
I'D RATHER BE ON THE SIDE OF
JAPE CHAPELLE WHO I THINK HAS
SPOKEN SO WELL ABOUT THIS, KEVIN
HART, JERRY SEINFELD, I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE ALL OF THEM TO BASE
THIS ONE.
THAT WOULD BE AN INTELLIGENT
DEBATE I WOULD GO TO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dagen: JUAN?
>> Juan: I THINK BEING RUDE TO
PEOPLE, INTENTIONALLY DEMEANING
AND BULLYING PEOPLE, I DON'T
THINK IT'S FUNNY, I AGREE WITH
HIM ON THIS POINT, IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE DOING, YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO PAY THE PRICE.
THE THING ABOUT AMERICAN COMEDY
AT ITS BEST, IT DOES CROSS LINES
AND THAT'S WHY IT HOLDS UP A
MIRROR TO AMERICAN SOCIETY AND
WHY WE LOVE AMERICAN COMICS,
FROM LENNY BRUCE TO, ALL THE WAY
TO CHRIS ROCK.
THAT'S THE BEST OF AMERICAN
COMEDY.
BUT IF YOU'RE GOING TO LOOK AT
CANCEL CULTURE, DAY AGAIN, LOOK
AT IT IN TERMS OF THE POLITICS
OF TODAY WHERE CANCEL CULTURE IS
A BIG GRIEVANCE ON THE RIGHT.
LIZ CHENEY JUST GOT CANCELED FOR
SPEAKING THE TRUTH, MEANWHILE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE IS MAKING
HITLER-LIKE COMMENTS BUT SHE
DOESN'T GET CANCELED SO YOU BET
TO START SAYING, ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT COMEDY AND THE AMERICAN
TRADITION WHERE ARE WE ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT'S JUST FITS YOUR
POLITICAL TASTE AT THE MOMENT?
>> Dagen: WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
IN COMEDY, JESSE.
NOTHING IS OFF-LIMITS BECAUSE
HUMOR HUMOR AND LAUGHTER
ACTUALLY MAKE THE WORST
SITUATION, EVEN TRAGEDIES,
BEARABLE.
>> Jesse: RIGHT, SO, I THINK
GREG TOUCHED ON IT A LITTLE BIT,
SETH ROGEN IS TALKING ABOUT
HIMSELF, HIS PAL JAMES FRANCO
WAS ACCUSED OF A LOT OF
MISCONDUCT BY WOMEN WHO WERE
MAYBE EVEN 17 AND AT THE TIME
SETH ROGEN MADE A JOKE ABOUT IT
AND NOW YEARS LATER AFTER THE
ALLEGATIONS HAVE BECOME A LOT
MORE CREDIBLE AND A LOT MORE,
HE'S NOW APOLOGIZED FOR MAKING
THAT JOKE BUT -- COMEDIANS ARE
COMPLAINING ABOUT
CANCEL CULTURE, THEY ARE
COMPLAINING ABOUT WOKE CULTURE
BECAUSE WOKE CULTURE KILLS
COMEDY AND MAKES EVERYTHING
BORING, THEY'RE NOT GETTING ANY
EDGY MATERIAL ANYMORE.
WHEN THE EDGES HERE, EVERYONE
JUST HANGS OUT HERE NOW.
THE EDGE HAS COME BACK SO FAR NO
ONE IS PUSHING IT.
EDDIE MURPHY, GEORGE CARLIN,
THEY ARE NOT COMPLAINING THAT
THEIR JOKES DIDN'T AID WELCOME
AT THEIR JOKES AGED BEAUTIFULLY,
LIKE DANA PERINO.
>> Dana: WHAT YOU NEED, WHAT
YOU NEED?
>> Jesse: ANYTHING.
>> Greg: I CAN'T TELL IF THAT
WAS A COMPLIMENT OR NOT.
>> Dagen: I WILL JUST END WITH
THIS, YOU MENTIONED EDDIE MURPHY
OR LENNY BRUCE OR JOAN RIVERS OR
PAUL MOONEY WHO JUST DIED, THIS
BUMBLING BAG OF COWARDICE THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
SEGMENT WILL NEVER B